bonsoir l'ain je ne sais pas si cette
montée des marches étaient prévus depuis
de longue date dans votre agenda mais
elle révèle ce soir forcément un
caractère particulier avec le décès à
quelques heures de niki lauda
moi j'ai beaucoup pensé hier soir à
venir au pas venir parce que cette
journée c'était une soirée est bien sûr
une journée est très douloureuse bon je
pense qu'il faut continuer bien sûr mais
tout cas j'aurai une grande pensée très
émue pour lui ce soir
c'est j'ai pas de mots cac40 en
pratiquement de vie commune directe ou
indirecte et surtout une relation qui
n'a jamais eu le moindre le moindre
écart coéquipiers quelques exemplaires
ils et elles mettent rouge était l'élève
et on a on a tissé une relation d'amitié
qui a duré tout le temps et on a eu à
presque un parcours un peu similaire on
a été
patron d'écurie on a été commentateur on
a été actionnaire d'equipe conseiller
lui il avait plus de succès que moi
d'ailleurs ces dernières années avec
avec mercedes à chaque fois qu'on a
parlé s'il y avait déjà l'amitié qui
était à présente jamais une fois vous
discutez vous tourner les talons en
disant bon mais ce qui m'a dit un truc
pas pas bien pas clair c'était et c'est
vraiment une
la race des seigneurs et vraiment il a
il a beaucoup souffert enfin dans sa vie
après son accident sans jamais se
plaindre toujours en allant de l'avant
c1
c'est un vrai exemple pour le monde
d'aujourd'hui c'est daniel brühl qu'il
interprétait au cinéma parce qu'il ya eu
un magnifique film c'est vrai qu'il ya
une rivalité entre james hunt et et lui
comme il ya pu y avoir en travertin cela
et vous c'est complètement différent
parce que ça arrive a dit elle a été
vraiment épisodique sur sur une saison
mais ça montrait bien et c'est vrai que
ça suffit de moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
parce que
nicchi était enfin james est un peu
caricaturée nicchi était comme il est
dans la commune et dans la vie mais avec
beaucoup de
pas d'intégrité l'intégrité morale qui
est absolument incroyable et c'est très
dur pendant 40 ans 40 50 ans de faire ça
et ça vient aussi du fait que toute
cette génération avant d'arriver en f1
ils ont fait des trucs incroyables pour
y arriver c'était déjà un chemin de
croix et c'est comme ça qu'ils gardent
aussi 7,7 cette mentalité pendant toute
sa vie donc c'est vraiment rendre
hommage à ce genre de personnage merci
beaucoup l'un bonne soirée